hello I'm Jimmy and I'm David and today
we're reviewing the official first
trailer for transformers age of
extinction yes this is a reboot with
Mark Wahlberg there's no Shia LaBeouf
anymore things just got real and so
we're gonna see let's just dive in okay
so right off the bat I'm just gonna say
it a lot of ominous could have made of
steel looking shots of it there are Kent
farm we counted there are 11 black
slacks almost every shot in the
beginning as American flags so if you've
seen Armageddon okay it's a lot of the
same imagery of this sort of blue-collar
America look Michael Bay said many times
in interviews that's exactly what he
wanted to the point of like an excessive
amount for Armageddon and he's bringing
it back with this movie yeah now okay so
if you know anything about Mark Wahlberg
on the movie the rules he's play it's
like there's no way that he would let
his daughter dress yes because what this
girl is a teenager on high heels short
shorts and I guess she's not fun I don't
think she's actually tending to the the
animals there's Mark Wahlberg an
American flag welding mask let's go back
also mark wahlberg's looking at the
stock market on his screen daughter his
daughter is the new megan fox yes I
think she's of equal or Rosie
huntington-whiteley yeah um anyway so
yeah these this is gonna put her through
college just truck yeah found because
they're real Americans seems like a very
honest soon I mean one thing about
Michael Bay you can talk ill of him all
you want but he has some beautiful
cinematography it's a bit um commercial
though some people's call it to
commercial the point of ugliness but I
think it's great looking it's always
just pleasing he really likes he's
mastered the low shot yeah it's low wide
angle he says he always shoots and look
like the biggest lens you can find now
this line is just quite honest let's say
it I'm laughed out loud right I thought
this was the coolest line and any
trailer this year what say it he's got
we got polar very polarized opinion turn
I think we're just on the truthful that
is the coolest line ever that's the
cheesiest line okay I think I honestly
Betty those 40 takes part of that remark
always like I think we just found it I'm
kind of really have to say it do I
really have to say it I think it's
awesome because if you found a
transformer that's what you would say
and if it's so absurd and like okay
obviously like if we go back we saw that
shot that's a billboard that says
remember Chicago that happened and yeah
the third transformers movie you know
report alien activity so I don't think
they really called him transformers in
the other movies but we owe that like we
should try calling my number though we
should we should try calling that number
I think in this movie obviously is
making reference to the third movie and
it's also saying you know these from
alien robots are transformers we just
found one and he seems to be excited
about it so I guess that's a good thing
so moving on
I mean he's excited Chloe's I do I drink
I drink you this I do give the the
editor credit because they really slow
up the role in this one and it does
somewhat fall a similar situation Lori
art to transformers 3 trailer where you
didn't realize that it was Transformers
movie until you see shadow buff and then
yeah Optimus talking but that's like
almost halfway through so now we have
like our whole bad boys 2 moment going
on it's just American Flair [ __ ] local
anamorphic lenses these glasses are
amazing they really are thank you oh my
gosh this shot alone is just this is
just trademark Michael Bay Michael Bay
is patented that shot and there's
Optimus Prime explosions completely just
like how cool is that so someone in our
office compared to Optimus Prime to a
homeless person cuz he's like all
raggedy and beat down yeah he's in
height adjusts easy to the friend it
takes a first when it sinks see now he's
down on his luck it's just that it's
this could be Wally but instead of being
like small and adorable he's giant and
badass and can destroy things I don't
know what see that would be
so it's a new era brick I'm hoping for
boat transit error of the transformer
they're also clearly saying this is a
reboot you know the rules of change new
things are coming out we got Bumblebee
back though stanley tucci he was not
been initiated yeah we don't need you
but then there's like some buzz saw
spaceships coming this shot looks really
poorly composited I don't know what's
going on there but well there is a
comment I mean Avengers did this main a
steel did this Independence Day 15 years
ago did this alien robot that's right i
mean the shot always does look kinda
look the same that look american flag
again okay so i'll be honest like this
trailer is dripping with eye candy i
mean it's just like every shot is just
makes robots a teenage girl with blonde
or just explosions that's all you bro or
a cool car yeah it's like fat this is
like a little bit of fast and furious
here with like the green green
headlights so this movie this so look
this is kind of kind of reminiscent of
command steel yeah it's like sucking you
can see it's like it's something you can
see his boats getting sucked up right
here it's pretty cool it's a new take on
like the the giant robo destruction ship
I wonder if they put a boat in because
the boat is a Pacific Pacific Rim
trailer when the boat is being used as a
baseball bat it's kind of like look we
can use boats to this is amazing like
the Stanley Tucci's a great actor he
like I really believe that he's scared
and then he's scared I like dinobots now
we it's a little late that did the
trailer but we're finally seeing the
Dinobots and we're gonna see a t-rex
Dinobot I think his name is Grimlock
coming up here's I Dave ladies I believe
his name is Grimlock and I'm pretty sure
we're in China because I know they shot
a lot of this movie around Kong and it
looks like China to me
now they're fighting but in the other
the Super Bowl spot we saw Optimus Prime
riding him so maybe they become friends
I'm not really sure what's gonna happen
okay so what overall obviously you're
you're over the moon I mean I think this
is gonna be a great movie no point I
mean I say great is a great Transformers
movie there's a lot going on this that's
exciting they're an interesting art for
will say that there is definitely an art
to them yes I was I think people who the
credits for the people who made this
they've spent a lot of time on it and
that's good they did people spent a lot
of time on Worst things I guess you
could you could justify its existence
that way yeah well um I don't know I
think it'll do what do you I don't know
if we're past that point of like I think
in many gamers me know as long as it
goes in a new tone and it becomes
interesting it's gonna like them that
there could always be better
Transformers movies that's the thing
like the room for going up is very high
because I didn't really like the second
or third one well as we said you know as
they said this we're in a new era you
know the age of it yes farmer but I
think I think this one's gonna be great
I thought the first move transportable
which begs the question where were we in
the last three movies were we not in the
age of the transformer I mean really I
think it was more let's salt toys but I
think this one is gonna that was the
process no I'm saying if the new film
the fourth film is the aid they say said
it in the trailer is the age of the
transformer or was the last three movies
taking place I don't know age of giant
alien robot like I don't understand I
was just maybe the nanobots
anyone transformers age of extinction
comes out this year this summer it's the
summer so probably run July you know how
to be patriotic but uh David's really
excited yeah any last thoughts um I
think it's gonna be cool well you heard
of your first folks thinks it's gonna be
cool I got a really good kick out of
this one I thought it was really
visually visually stunning but Mark
Wahlberg yeah just don't take it too
seriously it's just meant to be it's a
robot movie yeah like that's what you
expect it to be and they will be a fun
movie alright until next time I'm David
and I'm Jimmy and let me know what you
guys think of transformers age of
extinction are you excited are you
disappointed do you want more robot
explosions in your face all the time
every year or I mean would you rather
have transformers be like a fast and
furious kind of foam where they make one
every year and it's just this new
adventure I would um but let us know in
the comments below until next time I'm
Jimmy from movie clips thanks for
watching